this show is brought to you by club w
club w is the most convenient way to get
wine
sent directly to your house right now
club w is offering our listeners 20 off
of your first order when you go to
clubw.com joey and even better club w
knows you hate paying for shipping so on
orders of four bottles or more club w
will pay for your shipping that's club w
dot com slash joey
show is also brought to you by meundies
go to meundies.com joey right now
and check out their men's and women's
underwear socks t-shirts they're very
comfortable sweatpants
go to my undies.com joey right now to
get 20 off your first order and shipping
is always free in the us and canada and
the show is brought to you by
datsuzara.com go to dsgear.com
and check out all their extremely high
quality functional gear made with hemp
textiles bags keys rash guards and much
much more
go to dsgear.com and use cobra joey to
save five percent
oh [ __ ] blow my mic
oh
[ __ ] wednesday
the 7th of september
the day the devil was buried at sea
raped
gang raped
dropped off at cosby's house
everything
it's a church of what's happening now
[ __ ]
jesus christ
[ __ ] tremendous
1987 slippery when [ __ ] wet
just tremendous i'm not a big bon jovi
guy
i hear he's a very nice guy
i was just going to ask because it
didn't it doesn't seem
like something that you'd be into but i
was wondering if it was because uh like
uh but springsteen has jersey and stuff
but isn't bon jovi from like philly no
bon jovi's from sayville new jersey
and uh
you know when i lived back there in the
early 80s he would play at a bar
he would play that jersey circuit
and i had heard of him but i'd never
seen him you know like nothing like that
and
then
when i went back
i think i saw them i walked out of
twisted sister there was like this
little
click sticky fingers they were like a
stone's
cover man cover band at the time before
i left jersey when i was younger and
that was it and then when i got to
colorado the album was out in 87.
and uh it was [ __ ] tremendous like
the impact i wasn't really a big fan of
the whole album right but i was a fan of
that song for some reason and they had
it on miami vice with willie nelson
and i lost my [ __ ] mind you know what
i'm saying we were talking about
something early on kill my mic a little
bit it's too hot it's too hot both of
the mics are too hot there you go i can
just turn your headphones down no that's
okay both of them [ __ ] things
we were talking about being spoiled you
were talking about a friend of ours
right that we know at the comedy store
and uh some of his attitudes that he
shares and his beliefs and lee was
telling me he couldn't [ __ ] believe
it
and i told lee that before my mother
died
that was me
i mean horribly oh i know i was spoiled
too but horribly it's just there's a
level of it
i did my own laundry
i was i had to go to shop right myself i
had to pay the phone bill she would give
me money for the phone bill and the
other bills she had to pay i had errands
i had errands but
uh early on i was horrifically
spoiled i mean the behavior i showed out
here when i was 10 towards my uncle
was horrible the behavior i had in miami
was horrible
and it's weird because you you've talked
about your mom being really uh strict in
certain ways and my mom like
i was spoiled but i think maybe the
reason why i never
i'm sure i did act spoiled at some
points but i think the reason why i
don't a lot is because like they would
like
they wouldn't stand for it like they i
never really got hit that much but they
wouldn't stand
like that i did all that type of [ __ ] i
was forced to work
it was a different type of spoilage
until about 10. i was very small and
like
you know when i was five
or something i would order chicken
delight
and she's like you're not gonna cook
you're not gonna eat dinner i just made
this no i'm gonna cook chicken in july
and she allowed it
so it went on for like a year i just got
my own dinner every day and five at five
first grade second grade in new york
city it had to be before you know
before i went to jersey in the third
grade before i went to catholic school
for a year i just ordered chicken
delight with my own money three pieces
of chicken the bun the jelly thing with
the french fries and [ __ ] and they
deliver to you yeah and i drink get
tahitian drink you ever see that soda
tahitian
it's in a [ __ ] can it's made by coke
or pepsi okay no i haven't seen a fruit
punch with
with how well punched no no
okay look it up tahitian something okay
but i tell you what okay so but to the
age of 10 i had that
kid spoilage but then something happened
when i was 10 or 11. i started becoming
a little klepto
and i started clipping one's money
tahitian treat tahitian treat
told you it was delicious
if it i used to switch up it was either
that
or ginger ale oh yeah ginger alex ginger
ale whatever the [ __ ] it is but the one
canada drug i'm a canada drive guy when
you show up with schweppes i have a
[ __ ] heart attack all right when i
see schweppes behind a bar i'm done i go
home i don't want to see schweppes
canada dry club canada dry [ __ ]
ginger ale and canada dry tonic ain't
[ __ ] bad either tastes like dick
anyways but at least i got more bubbles
than regular [ __ ] tonic canada dry is
the only [ __ ] i taste that's it i hate
that other [ __ ] schweppes
and that other stuff now they got like a
low sugar
ginger around the [ __ ] planet it's
not bad how about blast that out from
time to time with the [ __ ] doers or
something yeah you gotta have ginger ale
and my drink for a while was ginger ale
and amaretto it's like the sweetest
thing you could ever drink yeah but
don't do nothing i need something to put
a [ __ ] clink in my [ __ ] arm you
know what i'm saying that's crazy that
you said that well what i tried to like
i've i tried to like drink the other
night instead of smoking like didn't
just hang out with some friends
i couldn't get drunk
i had three
[ __ ] beers and it was just i was full
i couldn't drink anymore no you gotta go
back to the [ __ ] whiskies you would
drink it yeah i gotta go that's what you
need there's more beer in your [ __ ]
life
but
by the time i was 11 lee i got a
different type of spoilage and this is
the worst one
it's the spoilage mixed with
what's that word when somebody knows
nothing but they don't want to come to
terms with
whatever the [ __ ] it is i don't know
there's a word for that okay
like my mom
would really believe that i wasn't doing
this [ __ ]
oh um denial yeah she was in denial and
here she is in denial and i'm [ __ ]
going even crazy
because she's telling juan no he
couldn't have taken that [ __ ] 8 000
yes i did
in 20s and 40s you took oh my god you
know i was killing him
i found all his little stash spots where
he had that bail money he had that
[ __ ] other and by this time him and i
were not seeing eye to eye by the time
by the time i came home and i was at
mckinley him and i were not seeing eye
to eye how long did it take you to take
eight grand two or three months
i was buying bicycles and mini bikes and
selling mini bikes and wheeling and
dealing and no drugs at the time
basketball camps and sneakers and
t-shirts and
dinners and hamburgers you weren't being
like sneaky about it no i was mugging
him and if it wasn't that he had this
change jar filled with silver dollars i
was mugging him on the silver dollars
and then
it was very sad it's hawaii it was very
[ __ ] sad and my mom sat through this
and i i would wake up in the morning and
hear him
saying you have to do something with it
this is not this is not
it's not kosher
and my mom would say how come this
doesn't doesn't ever happen to me
how come i don't miss nothing
and that's what he argued because you're
his mother he's not going to take it
from you he's going to take him from me
and [ __ ] and
my mom would say i'm telling you he
would not take it from me
this went on for years then the drugs
came on
and he would tell my mom i smelled the
marijuana in the house and she would go
it's maybe the [ __ ] that was downstairs
it was me
i live with this [ __ ] today but
that whole i'm not gonna eat
like the last month of her life after i
got sick
was when she sat me down and said
everything's changing
you're gonna eat here every night
and i can see the pain in her face so i
i went along with it
you're gonna be every night at six to
eight
i'm gonna start doing stuff for you more
you know it was like but it was too late
i was already raised in my own way i was
already raising myself so
so but then uh do you change somehow
well when she died
oh there was no more rooms with air
conditioning and cable tv
nobody was gonna just give me a 30 bill
nobody was gonna
bring me food to my room all that [ __ ]
went out of my life
there was no more did you go to work
today oh no there was nobody there and
all that [ __ ] went out of my life i had
no time to be spoiled
if somebody offered me a room in a
[ __ ] basement next to a dead rat i
had to take it
yeah so all that spoilers like all that
i'm allergic to carrots and
you know i can only sleep in air
conditioning i came to a [ __ ] halt my
friend
but i laugh at these people that have
all these diseases and i think whatever
happens is a person goes to jail they'll
die
because they don't give a [ __ ]
they don't they don't give a [ __ ]
they don't give a [ __ ] you're gonna find
that that you can do just well without
the inhaler and them cigarettes you're
gonna be just fine without them
and anything else you think you depend
on like if i went to jail tomorrow it'd
be a week and a half before i got a
sleep apnea machine
[ __ ]
that's scary it's scary yes
but then
do you have an issue now like since you
had to deprive yourself throughout those
years and now like you just moved into a
house like does any of that stuff like
is it hard to like switch back now no no
no okay no
i'm still that because i know how fast
it all disappears
i witnessed something that a lot of
people don't witness in their life
i witnessed the rise and the fall
and i looked at why the reasons of the
fall were
and they always had to do with greed
they always have to do with stupid greed
you don't see you think that the golden
cow is never gonna stop it's gonna stop
it's gonna eventually come to a crash
that's a reality i know
what do you think i don't go on the road
every week what do you think i don't put
videos up all day why because the
quicker i do that it's the quicker my
demise
right yeah you follow me so i'd rather
be where i am right now do two weeks a
month i don't bother nobody i made a
mistake over money a couple weeks ago
now i'm paying for it when i
canceled nashville
and took that stupid [ __ ] oddball
tour
you follow me i made a bad decision that
i would never make that
under the circumstances i'm a firm
believer when you're going in with if
you like new england on sunday you
better bet new england on if you like
new england on monday you better bet
them on sunday
don't tell me new england all week and
like joey diaz talk you in tibetan
[ __ ] the jets because he's an [ __ ]
and you're a bigger [ __ ] for
listening to him
you know everything about new england
why would i [ __ ] talk you following
him saying to you never let somebody
talk you out of your original plan it's
a 50 50 toss up sometimes somebody uh
look at like a narcos they told the two
dea agents to stay back and then they
blew up [ __ ] korea
so it's always you follow me sometimes
it works in your favor but if you
believe in something like i was headed
to nashville to see my niece
also they call me and they throw this
extra money at me that i i can't use i
really don't give a [ __ ] about it
i really don't give a [ __ ] about it i'm
content in my life right and look at one
could put
so now i'm prepared for the next 10
years again because i wouldn't have done
that danny you if you follow him saying
to you yeah it's uh i think i i made
that mistake a lot when i would leave a
job too early like if i was like if i
got offered a job somewhere else i did
that a couple times
where
i got offered a job and like one time on
hell's kitchen they were like okay the
show's ending
you can start looking for jobs and i got
one right away
and i didn't get called back for the
next season of hell's kitchen and i was
kind of bummed i was like maybe i should
have stayed to the end
like it's i feel like people do jump
ship too early
well we either jump ship or we see
our eyes get bigger than our [ __ ]
stomach you know whatever that
expression is
and in my world it really didn't matter
because i knew i had to pay for my own
plane tickets my own bus rides
all that [ __ ] comes out of your pocket
and trust me that [ __ ] adds up
luggage twenty dollars luggage twenty
dollar space you know getting a cab with
tom segura and and the other guy and
next thing you know it's a 80 cab ride
we don't know where you're going
you know where you going
you don't love the hotel's [ __ ] 40
minutes from that [ __ ] airport
here you are budgeting 22.50 and you're
getting this 64 ap so i know there's a
thousand by the ways on the road
generally people don't know this [ __ ] i
know this because i travel i know that a
little cup of water is eight dollars on
a [ __ ] in the terminal you can't
believe you're paying [ __ ] fought 375
for a little thing of water you can't
believe it i won't you can't believe but
what are you gonna do diet thirsty get
on the plane [ __ ] yeah oh [ __ ] that oh
yeah i don't get lightheaded i need
water but
that you know they robbed you from a to
[ __ ] z oh it's terrible so i knew you
know you go for a [ __ ] donut it's
4.25 how can i [ __ ] donut a dunkin
donut before 25 you know just [ __ ] like
that that regular people don't think
about
i see it all they get surprised now can
you believe that the hotel lobby wanted
six dollars for a cup of coffee [ __ ]
yeah i do believe it that's the way it
is [ __ ]
that's the way it is [ __ ] what about
like room service menus those are always
and they add tip to it no room service
and room service will murder you
quicker than [ __ ] you know heroin
room service will [ __ ] bury you jack
because when you look at boom service
the check when it comes you almost die
all you see is 16.95 for those eggs
and that's a lot and when it comes up to
the [ __ ] thing they had 22 percent
plus like three bucks a three dollar fee
plus six dollars for the way to
play and you sit there going oh my god
i just paid
41 for two eggs three pieces of bacon
and two pieces of wheat toast
am i [ __ ] nuts
and i [ __ ] nuts
every time paul and i go away we're like
we're gonna get room service this time
and like the most we ever do is like a
dessert because we both look at each
other we're like we can't
how we're gonna spend 23 on eggs or like
sixty dollars on
people have no idea
people have no reality of what some
people do i have friends that we discuss
when you go out what's going on because
they travel for a living it's not
necessarily comics
one guy's an attorney i always talked to
he was in st louis and he goes he calls
me
and he goes i don't know how to [ __ ]
do it and i've been doing a lot longer
than you so i know the curve balls
you know where you could get water
where you could do a thousand things for
free and if not just start shoplifting
just start shoplifting at the airport
mingle i'm worried about airport jail
though pay for the [ __ ] magazine but
steal the water you know what i'm saying
pay for the newspaper they want three
dollars for a new york post at la time
at lax
yeah they want three dollars for a
[ __ ] daily news at lax you can't do
that [ __ ] that [ __ ] i just put it under
my arm and make believe i brought it
it's brand [ __ ] new what's the matter
you getting anxiety i'm getting anxiety
about because i have people with guns
there i don't i'm i would never i think
you're gonna get shot by uh for
shoplifting
i don't know you're almost worse than my
[ __ ] wife you know that
you're gonna get shot for shoplifting
are you [ __ ] crazy shot but i don't
also what am i gonna do call you and be
like hey i didn't make it back from
boston
dog when you get caught shopping there's
a thousand outs
first of all you start eating in the
[ __ ] store
you just pick it up like it's yours
and then you start eating it
you know when i used to [ __ ] fly
and i would sit by like i was the type
of guy i would sit in the airport all
day
just getting free plane tickets like i'm
that much
because i knew on southwest i could use
all those
so i would sit there all [ __ ] day and
i'd watch people like look how people's
how dumb people are
when people order those coffees i watch
with coffee they'd order
and they'd be talking [ __ ] and i clicked
the [ __ ] coffee
you would not steal someone's order i
don't give a [ __ ] 16 years ago what are
you gonna do when they come up to you
like i don't think you're i don't think
your name was diane they never got me
they never got me i wait for a guy with
his girlfriend that was in love eating
[ __ ] looking around kissing the huh well
he's telling me he's loving him dick i'm
drinking his mocha latte
[ __ ] him you got to pay attention
you got to [ __ ] pay attention
you do so if you don't pay attention
there's a thousand people like me at
that time that would clip you they'll
[ __ ] clip you in the side of your
wallet's half hanging out there's people
who take it and give it to you but
there's people who bump into you and
wait for that wallet to fall and they
put their foot on it
and stand there like they're looking at
a bird or something jesus i've i watched
this video these this guy did about uh
like the car theft in in newark
and they said like any like any if they
always look for people who are looking
at their phone at like a parking lot or
something and i always did that so i had
i stopped because it scared the [ __ ]
rule number one once you're walking put
that [ __ ] phone away
put that [ __ ] phone away if you're
walking
put that [ __ ] phone away i don't that
phone's in my pocket when i'm walking on
silent
i don't want to hear from nobody if i'm
[ __ ] walking
if i'm walking i'm looking around i'm
observing the [ __ ] trees we've had
this [ __ ] discussion all right i was
talking about in the car like if you're
sitting in like like waiting at like a
light or something crazy like you're
always looking dog put that [ __ ]
phone away every day somebody gets
killed because some jerk hoes on the
phone if you want to look to see who
texts you gives a [ __ ]
you know if you're driving
and somebody calls you and they can tell
you the same [ __ ] they're going to tell
you in 20 minutes call them back in 20
minutes oh yeah don't even answer the
phone you're driving with your luck you
pull over you stop at the light you pick
it up in a motorcycle cop and that and
drop them next to you and go pull over i
wasn't even on the phone you looked at
your [ __ ] phone and burbank they'll
give you a ticket for looking at your
phone
how do you think i know cause i got one
i'm one of those [ __ ]
just looking at it because remember my
clock in the subaru is keeps moving
right yeah i looked at the clock on the
phone the guy tapped next to me
god damn it that
and enough this is a little bit off
topic but it's about the cars i was i
was driving around the other day are
there like there's kids taking ubers now
which is crazy to me when they get
molested
you know the last eight [ __ ] months
every once a month there's a problem
with a [ __ ] uber driver yeah and i
heard that uber pays people off and
covers it up so the uber name i don't
[ __ ] know now you want to put your
kid in the [ __ ] what'd i tell you
about this area up here
these parents are raising kids
you know just ready to go down
ready to [ __ ] go down
you're not doing the kid no favor if
he's got a noob he's got a [ __ ] cell
phone
he's got the whole credit card or maybe
they put it on his credit card whatever
the [ __ ] you never know what these
[ __ ] people are doing uber why is he
uber because you don't want to give him
a ride to [ __ ] school
oh my god what a soccer practice you
don't want to give them a ride to soccer
practice because you're busy at yoga
class that's the only this area would do
that oh yeah this area up here where we
we podcast up here
uh 2-3 miles north from here
it's amazing i would go to that [ __ ]
ymca and see parents sitting there while
the mexican nanny was in the pool with
the child
those are the same parents that one day
gonna be looking at each other why do
you murder all those girls because you
didn't jump in the [ __ ] bull with him
you stupid [ __ ]
he knew you had no investment you
couldn't even jump in the [ __ ] pool
i see it at the parks when i go with
mercy i see it all the time it breaks my
[ __ ] heart
22 white kids 22 mexican nannies
we walk up there like strangers like
people look at us like why are you guys
here don't you have a nanny
like a tip to have a [ __ ] nanny
when i was growing up it was called an
au pair
and i was
i was in awe i was i couldn't believe
because my mom and we we
spoke about it today she she kind of
regrets not going back to work maybe
when i got into middle school or
something because it had hurt her now
but
she was always home and i couldn't and i
couldn't even wrap my head around
that your family would hire someone to
be a permanent babysitter okay so let's
say
you're
paul is working
right she's made her a partner okay
in today's world when you're an attorney
you gotta have the balls of a man i hate
to say that oh yeah because they don't
stop for nobody
they don't stop when it's a big time
you know a law agency from yeah you you
snooze you lose
okay as soon as you lose so that
maternity leave
she gonna be working
not a lot from the house
finishing up what she started
she still has to call him every day
because if she just disappears for six
weeks
by the time she comes back she's a
[ __ ] dinosaur right you have to
assume that you have to think that way
especially in law and i get that i
understand that the parents are busy
like you have a job by this time
hopefully you have a couple of your
shops open
we'll still be doing the podcast you're
busy
you're making a little money
i get it
i get it
worst case scenario you fly mom out here
or you get [ __ ] the mother-in-law
you're feeling you're looking great come
on you can babysit you can you cook all
day watch telemundo and raise the kid
you've raised three of them i got all my
great judgment in you
i'll come home at one after i finish
with joey and take them for an hour
you follow me there's there's the
solutions i didn't have a solution it's
me and terry right no and they're
solutions
but to be very honest like this is more
like paul will know
she worked real hard at law school she
wants to be a lawyer
i'm all for
her being as successful as possible
if i had a wish
yeah i want her to stay home and do what
my mom did
it's it's it's weird and she doesn't
want to and i i completely understand it
making 350 000 a year you're pulling
down 150 do the arithmetic right looks
like you'll be changing diapers
looks like you'll be mopping the floors
and cleaning [ __ ] and you know what it's
fine
just get rid of one of the podcasts
liz carmoch
hey how's it going what's up my love how
are you thank you very much for taking
the time and calling i know you're
training down there with the brothers
johnson down there
oh thank you how are you
i'm doing really well what about you i'm
doing pretty good too i got to tell you
man uh when eddie said you were
participating in ebi8
i was really excited but i'm really
excited because no [ __ ] liz komuch
i'm a big fan of yours man i'm a big fan
of your heart and your balls
so uh you always prove it uh i love that
you served your country
i couldn't i had felonies i [ __ ] up
but uh i really got a lot of respect for
you man uh
you did something that a lot of people
didn't do you just went in there you
didn't give a [ __ ] so i love you to
death this is an honor for me how's it
feel now eddie was telling me that
you're going up against mrs henderson
benson henderson's wife but this is the
second match you won the first match
correct
that's correct okay and uh
how did you win the first match by
points submission
uh no it's a submission only tournament
i won by a darce look at you
so now you're going back in against how
you
feeling i'm feeling really good we've
done a lot of work that was kind of i
took what would be kind of my first ever
vacation with my mom
and i got a phone call and like hey if
you want we have opportunity for
tournament i'm like oh and i'm stuffing
my face being fat because i'm on
vacation uh
and decided you know what let me just go
for it it's been so long since i
competed i can't not take it
uh so i really wasn't prepared but still
it ended up doing really well in the
tournament and this one i'm actually
training for so i have a lot more
confidence in it when was the last time
you competed in uh in a bjj tournament
oh it's been uh i think two years wow
okay i thought this was just recently
when you had beaten her okay
oh no this one was yeah but before that
prior to this tournament i haven't
competed in a tournament uh for two
years it's been with the ufc it's really
hard to to get a match it's actually
authorized right right right right no no
i understand how you feeling now how
many days have you gotten the training
in before this match
uh since since the last one i haven't
stopped training so i was on vacation
even on vacation still managed to do
some stops after that tournament i was
back to training monday morning
look at you all right yeah yeah where'd
you go on vacation
i just traveled around california
there's a lot of sights i've never seen
like the redwoods um i haven't gone up
to the san francisco the bay area so we
kind of drove up north with the hoya did
all the little you know the typical
california site seeing things in san
diego where are you from originally
uh originally from okinawa my mom's
originally from new york city okay all
right and no it's great driving up the
coast
and you can stop at some great jiu jitsu
schools
as good as they get all the way up to
san francisco you're stopping in some
great places so
yeah i'm sure you're in uh you're ready
for this this is pretty neat that you're
doing this for eddie eddie has uh
really grown a lot in my eyes i've known
eddie for 15
16 years before he even had the schools
so to see eddie do this it's a real
honor to be a friend to him
and now to have you compete competing oh
my god i'm so excited
me too
uh what are your plans on this you're
going to go back for the darts
uh again it'll be an opening in all
honesty up until that tournament i've
never landed at arsenal practice ever oh
it's it's one of those moves where i go
for it all the time and it just never
works out and in this tournament i
landed i won
every single match with the nurse
that's crazy
so i mean if if the opportunity opens up
again awesome um but i i expect that
after she saw me win the whole
tournament with darth she probably
should be prepared for that and
defending so there'll be something else
to open up so you got to hit it with
something simple
like a little kimura or something
or something completely crazy and off
the wall really complex
now what is your next ufc fight if you
don't mind me asking
i'm still hoping uh we kind of have
something that's uh coming down the
middle and it looks like we might have
something i can't release yet but i'm
really excited for it because just like
competing it's been two years since i
competed in jiu jitsu it's been over a
year since i can keep him at me oh my
god so hopefully something's done yeah
have you had injuries liz
just
i had surgeries and then i also had um
some family members my mom had to have
surgery so i helped take care of her and
some other things came up where it just
one thing after another hit and it seems
like i just had to take some time off to
really take care of that and focus on my
my personal life as well as my business
and now i've been able to get everything
back on track everything's doing really
great so now i'm able to focus back on
fighting and training now where's your
mom living now
uh now she lives in new mexico
oh wouldn't it be great if she was still
in nyc
and they put you on the card in november
and [ __ ] or something oh [ __ ]
oh oh my god she will lose her mind i
would too i would definitely i was just
thinking about it everybody dreams about
that oh where's your mom from
uh she looked all over new york city
okay yeah so it would be in the world
though
it would mean the world to her just to
go down because she's probably been to
the garden
for the [ __ ] circus you know
the harlem globetrotters i used to go
down there for everything too so they're
going down there to see you during the
fight
oh yeah we went to new york city to
visit some of our family and uh we went
we saw we went saw some shows there
the whole you know the typical
sightseeing in new york city and so to
go back in if i could actually fight
there
all right well i'll be amazing what the
petition for it liz what do you think
that would be great could you be ready
what is it 10 weeks out 12 weeks out
i haven't stopped training since uh
everything went went right my life got
all back on track i haven't stopped
training and i'm ready to go i can go to
two people so they asked me
well you know what man uh
i wish you nothing but good luck i mean
you have a great attitude
you took time to take care of moms and
in my world that's uh
that's aces so
you got good things coming to you you
know i i i don't want to take you that
long thank you very much for calling in
uh you have a fan here and i'll see you
sunday night my love
all right thank you so much good luck
all right liz thank you again
thank you bye-bye
let's call mooch ladies and gentlemen
went for ronda rousey fell a little
short you know what i'm saying but at
least she had the heart to go she didn't
get hypnotized right she didn't believe
the [ __ ] hype i have to give her
props i didn't even know she did mma uh
i didn't even know she did [ __ ] bjj
tournaments
so this is great you know for a lot of
people who don't know
ebi 8 is sunday on budo videos if you
don't live around it if you live around
the area it's at the orpheum dina i
think there's tickets still available
like i said listen man
i know eddie
when he was teaching at the uh
at the uh
boxing gym on santa monica
bomb squad the bomb squad now all of a
sudden he's got his own goddamn
tournament you know i'm saying so
uh to see this is unbelievable people
are talking about ebi rules
people talking about this and that so
it's just really impressive hold on one
second i guarantee this is my car
it could also be mine
the nsa is coming after us folks
[ __ ] up
not only that's interesting that you
brought up that conversation tonight
because i'm trying to write the book
and uh
where i'm at right now
is learning about life like i have to
write these chapters
for gordon these sample chapters right
and i'm still stuck like in 1981.
how old are you then 17. oh yeah right
after your mom died yeah so it was two
and a year and a half after my mom died
and all that spoilage [ __ ] i had
was going away
like i always did my laundry i always
got my own sneakers but there was just
that little attitude thing i had you
know i don't want to eat this
i don't want to do this and now i was
forced to do it
and it was
it was a realm that was even harder than
losing my mother
it was such an obstacle
but the reason why i lost it i always
say to you that my mother wouldn't have
died today
i would have been the softest man ever
i would have still been living in the
basement she probably been changing my
sheets i would have vacuumed i would
have probably still had a part-time job
or something
but i just wouldn't have been a hustler
you think you'd still be living there
like like in that same house listen man
if you're a [ __ ] man and you're
living with your mom and you ain't
married you're [ __ ] up
you know even if you're making [ __ ]
money i don't give a [ __ ] take the
basement tell her to live with you
upstairs i would
but this is for coming from a guy who
doesn't have a moms
so you gotta understand right everybody
is different i'm sure you don't want
your mom living upstairs from you now
every time you eat a star and come home
you think she's gonna come down and let
you and [ __ ]
you couldn't do it some people couldn't
do it no some people i couldn't i could
never face my mom a lot
i think it would eat me up alive eat me
up alive i tried while i was that year
or two i was getting high before she
passed right and they would i would
vizene banaca
cologne wash my hands
and i would really wait to not be that
high in front of her
i never did it ever in front of her the
only time was like one of the last time
she visited we had a podcast
and i went home and i had dinner and i
think
because she she she's kind of soft into
it a little bit
because when i came home and had dinner
i'm gonna eat like three portions of
meatloaf but other than that like i like
i think she was expecting something
different from someone who's really
stoned and when i was normal i think she
was like oh okay he's doing he's being
okay he's being safe i think i would
have had a hard time with it
especially now thinking about it now
when i'm raising mercy
i'm not trying to take that to the toy
store
i'm not trying to lure with that type of
[ __ ]
you know i'm trying to uh
she's been showing me every time she
goes to church they give her a hot wheel
a brand new [ __ ] hot wheel
so for the last month i want to go get
the track
you know me doug i'm [ __ ] 53 going on
10.
listen there's not a lot of games i like
there's not a lot of [ __ ] i want to do
in my life but there's one thing i
always liked
and that was [ __ ] hot wheels
since i was a kid i had the tire with
all the cars in the 24 carrier then they
had the 48 carrier on both sides i was a
hot wheel [ __ ] fanatic i got beat
with the [ __ ] hour you ever get
smacking one of those things in the ass
when you got white uh
uh underwear around you you're behind
the leg of one of those things
you have no idea what that feels like
getting hit behind your [ __ ] thighs
with hot wheels
would you throw them or what no it was
just she would tell me to pick him up or
something and then she told me go to her
room and she was cleaning him up as i'd
run by
she'd whack me one of those [ __ ]
things
you get whacking one of those [ __ ]
hot wheels jack you know you've been
whacked you understand me so
i always liked a monopoly i had i had
all those dumb games i had please don't
spill the beans i had all those stupid
[ __ ] games
but nothing got my dick harder than
playing with [ __ ]
uh hot wheels
some of them the doors opened
i couldn't do a lot of damage i didn't
have to be a mechanic some of them the
hoods opened
you know all i had to really do is put
the [ __ ] track together it took me a
[ __ ] six months to learn how to make
a loop-de-loop the car would always fall
from the [ __ ] top that's the
that was the first rubik's cube you
understand that's the first [ __ ]
thing they give you when you're like
five and it [ __ ] your world up because
they keep doing it on tv and you can't
get it to lieutenant and you can't do it
the loop-de-loop they had a scam so what
you had to do is you had to buy the
track they gave you but then once you
got that thing they threw a bite away at
you mattel they said ah if you want the
loop-de-loop you got to get the extra
extension so you get that extra power
down your [ __ ] living room
and then if you watch closely in the
commercial that's what they had they had
the extra [ __ ] extension on it so you
had to go back to the [ __ ] store and
get the extension that came with an
extra [ __ ] car you know i'm saying
they banged out that [ __ ] mattel
then you took it back home now you
[ __ ] call loop-de-looped
that that's correct
does that even still exist what hot
wheels well like just toys like that for
kids yeah
i'm telling you i'm
go online see what kind of hot wheel
tracks they got all right a garand
[ __ ] t they got [ __ ] that'll blow
your mind now i'm scared to go down to
toys r us because i know i'm gonna get
the big [ __ ] track from my office and
put it right in there and i don't give a
[ __ ] ooh they have a four lane one this
is what i'm talking about
when i was growing up you had a one
laner that's it you had one [ __ ] lane
then they had the two and the three to
race around and [ __ ]
come on now my dog and then you get the
car later on that's actually electronic
and it flies around i forget the name of
that one i don't know what the [ __ ]
name of that one was that's a small one
too i know it's not hot wheels but i had
one that was like kind of electric and
you had like a little trigger and it
would race around do you know what
that's called that was [ __ ] fun i had
something like that i just don't even i
vaguely remember it to be honest i think
but i can't uh
i can't raise mercy how i was raised
whenever i travel i bring mercy
something from the airport 6.99 one of
those [ __ ] uh
dollars they have i forget the brand
they were big beanie baby oh yeah
okay it's just 6.99 whenever i go there
wherever i go to cvs i bring it back a
[ __ ] beanie baby okay
that's the extent of it you know i i she
said no or something the other day today
and i got mad and i said
next time you say no to your mom i'm
gonna put you in the room you know
she went in there by herself
that's the type of soldier she is
she put herself in timeout no it's uh
i don't want her
to be like me at any [ __ ] age
they were telling me [ __ ] at an early
age that they should have been [ __ ]
telling me and that you know people
can't handle that [ __ ] when you're an
adult never mind a [ __ ] five or six
year old kid
and that's why i was acting the way i
was acting
in hindsight i think about this [ __ ] you
know so there's
certain things i knew and certain
privileges i had gotten and they should
have never [ __ ] done that with me you
can't do that with a child
so i learned from it so now i know how
to raise mercy without that [ __ ]
when i see these kids
in
a mentor boulevard at the audition
places and they have their head shots on
the floor
and there's people who need a seat and
they got three seats taken and and the
parents should go pick up your [ __ ]
what are you crazy
but that you're giving your kid a
certain power to think who the [ __ ] they
are
by acting that way and you can't give
your kid that power at the age of eight
or nine or ten
you know that's why i don't want people
calling me all the time hey have you
considered
we made a thing for your daughter if you
want to put a head shot in there you
don't want i don't think so
i don't think so
no i don't think so not even at that
early age i don't think so yeah she'd
get a college tuition by getting a good
commercial
but you know what what if she gets into
that life and she buys into an early age
i didn't buy into it because i was dirty
[ __ ] something when i did my first
day
really you were that old like because
you came here like 32 right something
like that no i came here
in 97 so i was 34 years old
how
how would your life have been different
if you didn't go to
prison
i was always doomed for prison really it
was either get me down
or get me later i'm very happy it
happened when it happened
very [ __ ] happy it happened when it
happened
they were either going to get me that
time or they were going to get me in the
next city
for something worse or something worse
or something
who knows
the worst thing you could let a [ __ ]
cocaine junkie think is that he could
get away with things
especially with a weapon
i would have been a different person
everybody changes once you get away with
something like that
you got a certain [ __ ] anti
so i'm very happy that happened when it
happened
it shattered my life for a while but
i don't know how i did it i put it back
together now i respect that side of it
you know what i'm saying
right i i just meant more along the
lines of like
the way you were with like the the drugs
and and
robbing like if you had come to
hollywood at like let's say
24. no i would have never made it
i went to that weed store yet that
up here and i seen them do something
very [ __ ] weird
okay i seen them at 10 15 in the morning
going empty fill up their atm bag
but they basically went out there with a
[ __ ] shopping bag filled with money
and they filled the atm machine right in
front of me
i could either sell that information
or i could take some guy to kick in the
door and i'm there with you
with a walkie-talkie a piece in your ear
guiding you through the whole thing
and you have to do it right but you're
going to walk out of that with some loot
but you still got to get the owner take
them to the safe because they got cash
in that dental report they don't put in
the bank they put the credit card
receipts in the bank and they hold on to
that cash and that's how they rotate
that reefer
so if you go there or somewhere close to
there there's a safe with 200 large
somewhere
and that's a nice weed store so they got
loot
this is how my eyes were
25 years ago
it sounds like they're still that way
though well like you still notice that i
still notice it
i still notice all the mistakes if i go
in there one more time at 10 15
and i see them doing that at 10 15 they
don't
they don't
what are you gonna do 25 years ago no
not now okay 25 years ago they don't
i'd figure out how to be in that 10 15.
but the problem is they have your id
so you couldn't do it i have to sell the
information to somebody who was liable
somebody i knew that would go in there
and do the [ __ ] thing clean
and the only way you could do it was
like i told you today
is go in there
you know
pull them all in the back
and explain to them what you want and
right away shoot somebody in a kneecap
let them go down let them yell and [ __ ]
take the owner right to the back
you've got a guy covering everybody
and he opens up the safe and gives it to
you
you give him back 10 grand tell him you
love him and then you'll see him again
and run the [ __ ] out there you take that
car
and you fly the other [ __ ] direction
on uh cold water
and
you pray for the best and you got both
[ __ ]
roads right there you can hit the 170 or
the 100.
that's something i think i'm going to
see you later somebody that guy's going
to freak out
somewhere along they have to have a
switch car
and break up because that could be the
three or four of us
now it's not money to [ __ ]
retire in the cayman islands and buy a
hotel no
but when you're a street piece of [ __ ]
50 000 is a lot of loot for [ __ ] 15
minutes work
plus a jar arefa
because you know i'm taking two or three
jars of reefer with me
but that's how loose they are lee
they're that loose
i saw it
i and i think i know the answer but you
never get tempted like if you if like
not even like i'm okay like that's
probably a bad example i'm not saying
rob a store but like let's say you were
at cvs right and their deposit bag was
on the counter and there was no cashiers
no
there's cameras everywhere today are
they either gonna find me in a week
or they're gonna find me in six months
but they're gonna find me because i'm
gonna take those posters and send them
to all the cbs
and eventually somebody's gonna go and
i'm i'm talking about
i hate to say this word am i talking
about now or am i talking about six
years ago before the podcast either one
when every once in a while somebody
would say that guy looks familiar no
you're following me i'm talking about
before the longest yard and [ __ ] like
that
they're gonna get you in a month now
with cameras you basically can't do
nothing see there's more cameras out
there than what you know
oh yeah like all the street lamps and
stuff so when you're walking down you
cross from the [ __ ] train in north
hollywood station
and you walk to all those [ __ ] bars
there on lancashire you have like one
two and the bar on the corner of the
federal where they shot the sons of
anarchy across from that [ __ ] place
right there
whatever you do there
whatever you do there is on tape on 18
different cameras
plus what's flying around you
know the drones and
it's uh
there was this thing and i it i was just
someone destroyed something the other
day but a drone caught them like they
they would caught them destroying like
this natural
formation
and it's ju it's
it's getting kind of like it's good that
they caught that i guess but
it's getting kind of weird like it's
getting kind of scary to go outside now
no it's not you don't think so no it's
scary depending where you go
and what time you [ __ ] go
i
i i i just keep looking i was thinking
about you today first of all you leave
the house you're in a positive [ __ ]
state of mind right okay
you don't have to have a gun no you
don't have to have none of that stuff
you leave your house
it's a beautiful day to be alive even if
you got two dollars in your pocket
because you're alive okay you walk down
the [ __ ] street
you're walking your chins up your chest
is out you're breathing
but the beautiful thing is you're not
looking at your [ __ ] phone lee
if you pay attention
america is a beautiful [ __ ] thing
well let's say i take you like oh yeah
you're a big favorite take me down to
mexicanville to get heroin
and and i leave you in the car by
yourself and you don't really know the
game you're going to get mugged
you put yourself in that position now
listen i mean you could be going right
now to big wings after this right we
walk over
we go across the street the light's
perfect i know a guy runs a red light
and kills us both
there's a percentage of that there's a
percentage that when we go to big wings
to get wings [ __ ] johnny goombah is
going to go in there and shoot a bunch
of us
because he hear somebody [ __ ] this
girlfriend
listen man you can't live like that
you can never live like that i would
never want somebody to live that way
things could happen all the [ __ ]
timely
bad things could happen all the [ __ ]
time
and then
and in the weirdest [ __ ] situations
right yeah and that's and that's the
[ __ ] scary part like if you keep your
head on top
and you're not looking straight ahead
and you're watching the cars coming
and if you walk down the street and for
some reason
it's 82 degrees but that guy's got a
hooded sweatshirt on and there's a bump
under his [ __ ] shirt
or or you know there's a lot of things
you can't control if there's an
earthquake and a building falls on your
head you ain't [ __ ] the hulk
you ain't holding up that [ __ ]
building right but you you can't listen
in my world it scrambles through my
world from time to time what if i get on
a [ __ ] plane tomorrow on the plane
crash
what if i get out of playing holly bob
when the 40 [ __ ] thieves are on the
[ __ ] plane what if i get on the
[ __ ] plane
and i got to talk there's a thousand
possibilities in your life
but you got to live your life
you can't
listen you know why i know this lee
why because i told you once i told
everybody to listen to this podcast
there was nobody that's more scared than
i am of life
if i would be a millionaire
i would stay in my house all the time
yeah that's what i'm saying and you
would know that but it wouldn't be
because of fear
it would be because yeah social fears it
would be because of a thousand fears
but it wouldn't be fear because the
world might [ __ ] end
you don't think i worry about my wife
you don't think i worry about my child
you don't think i worry about my friend
timmy driving a truck in new york all
night
you don't think i worry about the
agostino driving on the 405 all [ __ ]
day you don't think i worry about tommy
used to live in the [ __ ] van
i know i know the reality is that tommy
east and tommy easton knows the
realities
of living in a van
but you know it's when kate came in here
it's eight months ago and she was
talking about moving the van obviously
you don't know the realities of living
in a [ __ ] man no
you know listen man bad things happen to
good people
bad things always happen to great people
and it breaks my heart
it breaks my heart you know right now
tonight i could leave here some guy
comes up looking for [ __ ] [ __ ] and
he shoots you in the [ __ ] chest
no reason
no rhyme or reason you had nothing to do
with his [ __ ] world
and you're gone
that could happen also
a lot of things happen like that that
but you always have to live your life
i i do try to push it out like it's it's
not i i i i don't feel like it's
something i
dwell on all day but
i do all that at night there's one one
night every 10 days that i lay down
a horrible thought comes to my mind
about my family or my daughter or myself
and i have to actually get up
the reason why i have to get up is
because it's a reality
[ __ ] i could pass it through my mind but
i can't digest it
so i just
do what i was doing smoke a number watch
tv for a while and get the thought out
of my head and say a prayer
because i listen if you think at 15
16 i thought my mom was gonna die you're
[ __ ] crazy right you're [ __ ] crazy
who thinks they're gonna get up in the
middle of night and find somebody on the
floor whether it's your mom your uncle
your sister your brother who who in this
right [ __ ] world nobody
that's the last thing anybody ever
thinks about
that's the last thing anybody thinks
about
when you guys go to dinner and we crack
jokes for an hour and we giggle and [ __ ]
and
you know we tell stories and then you
get in your car and i go in my car and
somebody else goes in that car and we
say goodbyes and i'll see you tomorrow
what time late 3 30. i'll see them when
you get that call for in the morning
that he got hit by a drunk driver but
wait a second this is a [ __ ] dream
this is a [ __ ] dream
that's the same way i felt
when dominic special died that's the
same way i felt when anthony balzano
died he just i just saw him at six
o'clock
what do you mean he went to pathmark
at nine o'clock at night i just saw him
at six he was going home but then he was
gonna study for a math testimony
you understand me things happen in life
that's what makes life live is that
things happen
people pass and
one day you have to learn how to live
without them
somebody passed in my life a couple
years ago
it's really weird the friends you gather
and the relationships you have with them
and some of them pass and and you say a
prayer for them you send flowers you go
to the funeral you think of them from
time to time
i have a friend that passed maybe four
or five years ago maybe right before
around grudge match
right like i talked to him while i was
shooting grudge and he was a dear friend
of mine
he's the guy that took me out of [ __ ]
jersey
he talked me into going to colorado with
him and buying a car and putting it
under my name that he crashed it
and
uh was just uh we hooked up in
83 and obviously we were friends until
he passed three years ago
and it was a friendship that i talked to
him once a week
you know when i was back there i don't
meet with a lot of people
there would be one night a week
in 93 where he would pick me up on
monday nights
we'd drive down the shore together we'd
go on those boat
we'd go back to his house eat the fish
we'd smoke pot we'd watch a movie then
we'd go to bed
and we'd both he'd drive me back to new
york city the next day at 4 45 in the
morning
i'd be by madison square garden at
[ __ ] 5 30 a.m walking around why so
early because that's when he was in
charge of all the window washers
in like six or seven buildings him and
his brother worked at the world trade
center for a while and they moved him
around
but i spoke to him you know
various times when he came out here he
was in huntington park
and i actually scheduled the gig down
there it was like two days after my neck
surgery with the fat ball
i actually scheduled a gig down there
just so i could see him and he came with
his brother
and i had a great time with him and
another time we went to [ __ ] atlantic
city
and on the way there we were eating
those contaminated crab legs with blood
on them and [ __ ] we got a call from
linda road to go to connecticut and do a
comedy gig he drove me
and uh
just just [ __ ] like that you know
and sure enough a couple years ago he
passed and i gotta tell you something
i still keep his number my phone
i got his number on my phone nico
foley's number on my phone
i got like three people who punched the
ticket in the last three or four years i
kept that [ __ ] number just because
that's the type of type of cycle i am
they're not they just
i'm just having that phone got
disconnected for a few weeks i'll bump
into them someday you know what i'm
saying i keep it that way
but jimmy i think about
once a day
i'm craving the reason why i've been
thinking about him the last five days
he used to make this dishly you ready
tell me he gets spaghetti he'd boil it
good start
boil it boil it boil it boil it nice
nice he had it perfect
while he was cooking the [ __ ]
spaghetti he'd fry up some bacon
all right and then you take the bacon
off and he let it get really really
crispy
really really crispy really really
crispy really really crispy
and then he'd take the [ __ ] spaghetti
out and he put it in the strainer and
then when it was in the strainer he'd
throw a piece of [ __ ] butter in that
[ __ ] and he'd start right there
working it with the butter and [ __ ] then
he threw that right into the [ __ ]
thing
with the bacon not yet but he throw the
bacon on top of that
some more butter on top of that and then
he'd get an egg yolk
and throw the egg yolk on top of that
and he'd mix it in real [ __ ] good
he throws some salt and pepper on that
[ __ ]
and lee it was
delicious delicious it sounds amazing
delicious oh but you got proteined up if
you lifting weights forget about it he
would cook a big pot of it once a week
and just put in the freezer on the
refrigerator i'm sorry
and from time to time you could take the
pot out and just take a bowl put in the
microwave oven and bang get yourself
some [ __ ] pasta
the bacon bits were tremendous how he
made them i could never make it that way
and i've been dying to make it for my
daughter
because it's something different it's
like a puerto rican fellow genie alfredo
right uh
but i don't think she'll eat it with the
bacon in it she doesn't like bacon ah
what the [ __ ] knows
she eats bologna and she calls it salami
i don't
it's been fun going up on tuesday nights
i've been enjoying it
lee that was the weirdest thing ever
last night
people let me explain something to you
you could do comedy
when you first start out in comedy
you do what's called open mics and that
way you show up and you sign up
and there's a bunch of [ __ ] who
think they're movie stars
and they get up and they do horrible
material and you wait there all night
you do comedy in front of other
comedians
and it's help it really is hell it
really is uh
it's like going to [ __ ] die every
time you go to those places because
emotionally
you [ __ ] die it's been really i don't
know how comedians develop in open mics
because
very rarely do you get any positive
reinforcement so i'm like how do you
know what is good because all you're
learning how to do is becoming a
wordsmith at that point
you're just going up there you're just
hitting numbers
open mics are numbers i don't know what
the magic number is for lee syed
for joe diaz it may be eight 850 open
mics but for lisa
right now where i see
maybe 200 open mics and you'll be
feature active no yes i don't think i
want to be no no no no no no but it's
good that you're doing it because now i
could take you on the road you should oh
give me the small hundred you do eight
shows that'd be fun sure be fun you're
not doing nothing else in your life
i
i never thought
this was anything because you know i i
it's a story that everyone knows that i
didn't want to talk on here
but now like
i'm sorry i'm like [ __ ] i can't shut
you the [ __ ] up that's true that's
awesome now i gotta smack you twice to
talk and 18 times to shut up you're like
a crime relocation witness with god
leah no no no let me tell you something
i
love going to the comedy store and i
love going to the lab factory
and i love going to the improv
but i've been doing it for 20 years guys
in january
and you go to a comedy club
not to stay there
it depends how you use it you know
the comedy store is a great club when i
go in there i go to work bro
it's work
10 years ago
it was a little bit more fun
when you're doing more rooms like last
night then you have a thing called these
open mics
which
people have been doing comedy over 10
years they don't go to them
your pride just says i'm not going home
no more
i've always known
that that's the heart of comedy
i always know that when i need to
improve
or i need to
uh
be thankful for what i've done and what
i have
i have to go to open mics
and years ago it would be those mexican
rooms
because it's very weird to go on stage
at the comedy store when you first get
here and have gary shelling bring you up
and then you're bringing up dice
but at the same time that same night
i was bringing up a mexican dude with a
limp
and another one that stutters down in
some cougar room and [ __ ] pomona
do you follow me that must [ __ ] with
your head
it didn't [ __ ] up my head it doesn't it
made me a better comedian balanced me
out it showed me that comedy was comedy
it doesn't matter who the [ __ ] you're on
stage with
you got to work the same [ __ ] way
whether
jesus dice is there or [ __ ]
dave chappelle is there or some open mic
kid from [ __ ] redlands
it really doesn't [ __ ] matter that's
what that taught me
so for years i would go to clubs at
willy rand philly baseballz iran that
you get stabbed at
all right but at the same time i ended
up at the comedy store i knew the other
spot
so no matter how bad it was in that room
you follow where i was working at i was
working both sides of the [ __ ] fence
just to balance my head out right
so it wouldn't overwhelm me
that's a smart way to do it i had to
leave
i had to
so like do you think if people like just
start going to the store and get passed
right away like you got passed right
away and if you were just doing amazing
spots
do you think i got passed at the comedy
store the same way i got my blue belt
okay
i was a hard worker i put together a set
it took me a long time it took me six
years of my life to get to work hard to
get into the comedy store and i'm not
gonna lie nobody the first two years i
was [ __ ] off
i was [ __ ] off so for four years i
gave up everything i lived in an office
i went to [ __ ] jail for arguing with
some chick's boyfriend and getting
arrested for domestic violence i lived
on scraps josh wolf helped me out i mean
it was a nightmare i lived in a basement
with a [ __ ] bed and a bench for
dinner it was completely of who the [ __ ]
i was
it was completely out of my comfort zone
but the whole time i was [ __ ]
evolving and i wasn't even knowing it
i wasn't even knowing it i was shedding
that skin and i wasn't even knowing it
i wasn't even [ __ ] knowing it so it
took me basically six
years i was to that point now was i a
good comic to be at the store
no i've seen better comics i got into
the store
but she liked characters
and that's what i had on my side
and that's i mean that's not a knock
against you
no but here's the problem
she gave me a run
and in that run i developed into a
comedian somewhere another not a great
comedian not even very very good
comedian
i developed into a good comedian
what's a good comedian he's a comedian
for the comics in the back
he has a couple good jokes
you know he might bomb two nights a week
but the other two nights people going to
be scared to follow them
and that the
i think the other benefit to doing
multiple sets a night is i i never
really feel an itch to go up
i i enjoy going up tuesdays but when
we're all all standing outside after
tuesday i'm always like i wonder if i
could like there's a late one i could do
like it's fun like once you start doing
it you want to keep i want to keep doing
it it's like it has it definitely has
like a
you see what that's becoming up there
yeah it's all fun that's becoming what
my life was like in seattle
really for this special i wanted to take
myself back
when the agostino when the agustino said
he was doing a party up there
he called me and he goes joey this is a
nice place
i knew i was shooting the special
i go talk to the guy he called me back
he goes i got the room do you want to do
this september 8th i got sick obviously
but i've been up there every night since
july 16th
yeah or july 22nd or whatever the [ __ ]
it was i've been up there every one of
those nights
and the main reason why i'm doing that
is because i wanted to take myself to
square one for this special
i wanted to go back to that level i
wanted to go back to that level even
though i'm closing the room
i want to go back to that camaraderie
what made me happy about
comedy you know once you step over the
line and you're in those hollywood clubs
and those little side clubs they have in
santa monica you have a lot of agents
and managers and you have a lot of the
other side of the business people at
these clubs so people tend to act
differently
they tend to act differently they do
different material in front of agents
they try to smile you know
and that's great that's great i'm sure i
did the same [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know but at the same time it's nice
to do comedy
when there's nobody in me there
just regular bar people talking to you
that we met that really nice guy last
night that offered us a studio and a
camera
we met those dudes from kansas city that
were cool as [ __ ]
you know people have been coming out
it's 10 11 12 people
we end the [ __ ] show a little quarter
to 11 everybody goes home early nobody's
drinking and driving sometimes we have a
bag of weed
sometimes we sit around we get a bunch
of finger food for a bunch of guys
and you have no idea what it does for me
you look forward to it look forward to
it every [ __ ] tuesday
because it's a complete different side
of where i'm at now
i go to these shows and they're [ __ ]
sold out
and people want to hear certain material
and i don't blame them you know they
paid a ticket price they want to [ __ ]
see what makes them laugh and whatever
but it's also really nice to go on stage
without any of that pressure
last night the waitress said are you
guys going to stay and i didn't know we
were leaving
and she goes we think we really like you
guys to stay listen after i shoot this
special first place i'm going to be that
tuesdays at that place
just starting over because you
i i i'm not disappointed
but i look forward to certain things
that i want to see how jokes are
evolving for the special because i don't
really get to see you do those stuff
because you do it on the weekends
and you don't really ever repeat stuff
on tuesday so i get bummed out i'm like
well i got the same people in there and
what i'm trying to do is work a complete
different muscle
that's it and you know what every week
you tape it for me and i'll show you
that comic notebook with the dates
every week there's two lines in there
that might not be useful now
but sunday
they're going to be right there when i
need them someday i'm going to go
through that notebook
and they're going to be right
[ __ ] there where i need them so
you have like a
notebook of like just like lines i just
started this
since this special
willie's going to give me a notebook
with what i the set list
we're going to take from i don't think
you come down friday and saturday but
i'll bring my iphone the aggressive note
the agostino tape it he'll take both
shows friday and saturday
and then uh that tape i'm gonna send to
willie
and then we're gonna meet tuesday and
then we leave for austin thursday
austin i'm gonna start shaping it up
okay cutting fat i'm gonna tape the sets
then i come back tuesday night and then
boom wednesday i'm in new york city
i haven't decided i'm doing sets in the
city because i got to see a lot of
people this time
so thursday and friday and saturday i'm
in the city that's four more shows now i
come home and i'm home a whole [ __ ]
week
so the whole goddamn week i'm on stage
one night with you one night with willy
taping the next day just right now that
whole week that i'm not doing much i
don't even think i'm going to jiu jitsu
wow i'm just gonna go to ymca and throw
weights around in the morning after i
drop off mercy
so i could give it a bigger window
okay and train myself like i've been
doing two hours now i gotta go to four i
gotta find the spot where i can go to
every day and write without a phone
right without anything a diner or
something where i could sit in the back
and nobody will bother me for three or
four hours
that's my next bench we can't go to no
home because the food is so bad
i'll last two [ __ ] hours in there but
that's the plan now there's no more
wasted time and that
dark horse saloon is going to be the
nucleus of it yeah it's a grand total
i look forward to it too man and it's
i'm
it's i'm really surprised we're not
getting
more
um i don't know how to say it without
saying it the wrong way a lot
more
interest
no
more higher up comics
okay
you know i don't understand why
being that there's a lot of comics in
the valley
they go down to hollywood and on the way
back they could stop and
see that would be the ticket
if you promote the room like the show
starts at nine
but the show really starts at 11 30.
and that's when you get like three
[ __ ] good comics to come up and do a
half hour a piece
and you're keeping people there till one
o'clock that's the show that i'd love to
put together in the future and i would
host it
you know what i would charge them
another
time it would be yeah it would just be a
[ __ ] family tuesdays
so from nine
to one
yeah
have comics stopping like hitters like
people been on television
just to pop in and do 30 minutes in
front of 10 people
hbo reached out to them to write a
special damon wayans something like that
i used to see it all the time at the
comedy store but nobody's allowed to do
past 15 minutes anymore at the store
so now a lot of people aren't going down
to work out their sets
uh okay you're following me so they have
to give them a lot of sets a lot of
people don't want that
so 15 minutes here 20 minutes in and 15
upstairs forget it i'll just go to one
place where i could do an hour so how
can you get the word out to the comics
well they'll they'll find out eventually
that there's a good room on receipt on
tuesday [ __ ] nights
it's you know 15 to 20 people tops
you know eight of them are comedians and
just go up there and try your luck
come down what do you got to [ __ ]
lose
give them s'mores like i said last night
that's where it all starts
in those little [ __ ] comedy rooms is
where comedy [ __ ] starts
people come out of here and they ah when
i can't wait to perform at the comedy
store i can't wait to perform at the
improv
slow down nelly
slow down you walk in there there's
somebody in there you bomb they're not
going to put you back on stage
be prepared learn the [ __ ] terrain
and then go down there and test the
[ __ ] wars and don't get me wrong that
was the first place i went
i went to the store first and i got on
stage at the laugh actually the next
night
first two off the back just to see what
it was about
just to see what it's about right now
why not i'm going i'm moving here
and the storm went well how'd the light
factory go
i did well but jamie didn't like me he
said i was too dirty
so he told me not to come back there
until i cleaned up my act i was back
there two weeks later on a monday night
anything any cleaner no
and i continued doing that monday night
every night for about a year
the latin show that but he didn't work
monday night so he didn't have to look
at the lineups i was an independent
producer
so he had no idea i was performing on
monday nights
he never came in on a monday
i was always nervous i was going to be
on stage and when they were coming and
yank me off give me the light
never
we never came in on a [ __ ] monday
night
you never saw no that's one of the
things though that's
honestly one of the the most things
that's deterring me from what if i
wanted to do comedy like full-time
is like
hearing all these people's stories about
15 20 years of
struggle to get like i don't think i
have that in me well
let me explain to you the situation here
and especially from what i saw last
night
i seen a lot of guys go up
did you light the room on fire last
night
not really no you got a few laughs but
the most important thing was
your joke delivery was superb
your
promises were on the target like they
were like they were promises of a guy
that's been doing comedy three years
you know what i'm saying like you
already got like you already went
through
the first three years you're doing
michael jackson you're doing bill cosby
[ __ ] you're doing impersonation of
arnold lighting his dick on fire
yeah [ __ ] jokes because you got to
find your voice right so until you find
your voices when you start writing those
type of jokes
okay
you're following me
the only joke that was strong for me was
the only about her sucking your dick and
asking you if you want to do a green
diet
cleanse you can't do it you can't be
sucking a dick maybe she's doing
something about you know but who am i i
don't [ __ ] know nothing about writing
you don't see me on hbo
so what i'm saying to you is that
you have a lot going for you
do you have time to do comedy and go out
there
and make friends and talk to people oh
of course especially rooms in the valley
yeah
yeah you're a young man one beer never
hurt nobody
somebody at each of these open mics is
going to know you the agostino goes to
one tonight
right here valley college
honestly that's one of them
and okay i
that's one of the things i'm worried
about to be honest what but you'll like
it no no i i know i like it
i'm worried about where i would go to
get an actual response because i don't i
don't want anyone to be like oh he works
with joey diaz laugh harder no you're
gonna just do an open mic
tour that's it bars put yourself on the
list go in the back sit down get a beer
leave we're going to put you on 12th
okay
you're going to be a gentleman
you're not doing nothing at the house
except watching [ __ ] porn with
nickels
just the thought that you know that i
couldn't believe it
was talking about on stage that
uh you know some guy threesome with a
[ __ ] nickel
so
what i said was as i was getting into
chatterbait because
just cuz porn is kind of boring and i
have never paid anybody but it was i
looked it up because i wanted to see how
much a token was worth and it said the
performers get about five cents a token
so it's just it's like jesus christ and
they asked for 13 tokens
yeah sometimes like a hundred tokens for
like a blow job or something
five bucks to watch somebody give a bug
that's how much that's how much they'll
get i think they probably charge the
people who want to pay more
i should look that up that's another
funny thing they're probably getting
them from both ends
but your promises were good
your composure's good you're not nervous
not like yep they're [ __ ]
you're very confident and that's it and
you know what
that's fun
you're not performing for an agent
you're not performing for a showcase
from montreal no well come on up here
maybe i'll let you do my room in
hollywood where top people will say you
know what you're just doing open mics
and i got to tell you something
if i could stall life
i wish i was still in seattle with
brodie gavin josh wolfe tayna manu
al trifaris
al fox
rod long
i would give everything just to be stuck
up there still
living modestly
working out at some gym and just doing
that whole city circuit
because i gotta tell you something it
was the first time i felt
i wish i could have gone up there
without that girl
really that was my biggest mistake was
going up there after her
and chasing her she was a good girl she
meant well but
my temperament doesn't agree or women do
that type of [ __ ] so
it just didn't work but if i could do it
all over again oh my god it was one of
the best times of my life because
it was the first time
as a comedian that i was doing it
i'm doing this
this isn't like a dream anymore of me
crying in my room
circling [ __ ] goals and [ __ ]
those days are long gone
i'm in it
i'm in this [ __ ] right now
and to know that is tremendous
i know i'm not a star i know i'm not on
tv i know nobody's seen me
i know that nobody wants to call me from
hollywood behind me i know all these
things but guess what
i'm in the game now
for a while there i was looking out from
the outside
now i'm hanging out with other feature
acts
i'm going to shows with them
i'm getting booked as a feature
i got three ladies that are booking me
i'm going to feature at the uh
under comedy underground i'm a feature
at giggles
all these things are going on for are
you getting rich [ __ ] no
you're getting 250 to feature at the
underground 250 for a week a weekend oh
250 that we uh feature at [ __ ] the
giggles you would get 300 because the 50
from thursday night at the casino
whatever the [ __ ] that was tacoma
and as a feature act you have fifty
dollars a show
all the bars
if you were a headliner you got a
hundred if you were a co-headline he got
75 a piece so like let's say you're a
feature right in one of these cities and
they feature let's say someone features
for you
will they sometimes go out and do other
spots around after that that night all
night long [ __ ]
i would get in the car with josh wolfe
and we'd start over the [ __ ] bridge
and we'd pop a spot over there at 8 30
for the small 25
and then we'd shoot over to the comedy
underground and close the show there
because a bunch of comedians were
getting together for 70 of the door
and we'd get like 32 or something like
that
and then from there we'd get in the
[ __ ] car
and go to the artistic side of seattle
and there was a bar there that had cages
it was like downstairs i forget what the
[ __ ] the name of that place was
and they had like a you show up we pay
your
policy 25 bucks 20 bucks
who cares right you just made 120 on
your 40 dollars for the night
that's not gonna happen every night
that doesn't happen every night that
happens twice a week
and then the other night you pick up the
small 50 here the small 50 there so
you're walking around with 350 a week
in seattle you're getting 700 every two
weeks 1400 a month
you're paying rent you're living with
three guys in one bedroom
you're sleeping on the floor to the one
guy [ __ ] goes to rehab
you know it's one of those situations
but you got a shower you're warm
you got to have a car maybe not in those
days because we pick you up in those
days
and there was gigs all over bremerton
there was gigs all up and down seattle
if you hustled like when i got there i
[ __ ] awesome
i hustled so hard that one day craig gas
[ __ ] threatened me
why because i was at the gianta el lobo
whatever a lobo container with josh wolf
eating and he came in like is this the
guy that's [ __ ] working up a storm i
got to seattle on a saturday i was
featuring for john fox
in boise idaho on [ __ ] friday night
i went right to work
there wasn't no month training time
there wasn't no [ __ ] uh
evaluation time there was none of that
[ __ ] you didn't have the time i went
right to work
yeah right to work i got to see how on a
saturday
i went to the [ __ ] uh on seattle
underground that night i talked to a guy
named ron reed i had a reference
from uh rick kearns who's featuring for
me
columbus ohio
one of my comedy [ __ ] idols
one of the guys that used to headline
and i would feature and he'd make me
drive the truck
while he got [ __ ] lit
but i learned a lot of things from my
current he taught me how to write a joke
he taught me how to be yourself you know
he's been fired from every radio show
he's the real [ __ ] deal rick hunts
we're gonna have a good time he's
cleaning soba now he writes for ron
white and uh larry the cable guy and a
couple other guys so he's just a writer
cool but he wants to keep his head sharp
so we were talking to them and they go
[ __ ] it
come with me to [ __ ] columbus
that'll be fun but yeah i got to seattle
i used his name
i called that dude on monday i found out
that there was this lady pat something
that booked comedians i called her she
told me the facts of my avails
got them on there i called this cuban
dude who booked the improv at the time
wasn't an improv no more i faxed him my
avails i called this chick
uh donna something in portland oregon
faxed her my avails and i was off and
running jack
and i got a call thursday hey joe d is
john fox do you want to drive to boise
idaho with vince valenzuela
on saturday night for 150 dollars you
bet your [ __ ] ass
and that's it that was it a week i was
there and i was already plugging a
[ __ ] but i had been out every night
that week doing spots
making people chitchat
so are those
50 spots like the next step above open
mics yes okay
25 50 35 40 in the dinner
who's 25 and a dinner who's paying you
like the restaurant or like a booker you
have two different things sometimes you
have a private you have a club manager
that has a [ __ ] sense of humor and on
tuesdays he does karaoke on wednesdays
he does stand-up comedy thursdays ladies
night and friday and saturday friday and
saturday sundays [ __ ] you suck my dick i
put hot dogs out you come in you eat
what the [ __ ] is here you know it's that
type of bar mentality
you have that guys you have those guys
and they'll set themselves a budget
they'll say uh
our budget for the room here is 400
bucks
three comedians so the headliner gets
the most the feature and the headline
and the mc those rooms if it's a 400
[ __ ] budget
um
175
125 and the mc gets 100. now let's say
lee siyet
is a comedian and he walks into that bar
and he goes how are you doing
i like to put comedy in here and they
say okay what do you propose well you
got two options
i could charge at the bar but that'd be
difficult that confused about we got a
lot of regulars so why don't we do this
why don't you kick me [ __ ] 250 a
month
okay 250 a week to do the shows here
well let's start with two a month okay
so you got yourself 500 bucks
so you paid your now you you're a
working comic you live in an apartment
with three animals
okay okay you promote this show you get
75 people down there a wee week
so your budget's 250.
you're going to pay the m you're going
to pay the features 75 bucks
right right
[ __ ] you're not gonna make no money no
it's 250. yeah yeah but you get more you
should walk up like 150
dm the features should get 125 and the
headliner you get 175. you have those
type of rooms
so every week you just book a guy your
budget's 500 bucks they're gonna give
you 500 bucks
at the end of the show
what you need to do is divide it
sometimes you might get a guy that's
just starting to do 45. he's not a tv
act
but there's a [ __ ] laker game on
ain't nobody going to be here anyway
right you're following me and after the
lakers lose a win these people are going
to get up and leave they're already
drunk
so you could think that way there's
strategies in the bar you're not going
to book
[ __ ] uh
mark uh hunt
you know uh labor day weekend mark hunt
i'm sorry you're not gonna book uh
joe diaz
in uh
myrtle beach labor day weekend
why not because
nobody's going to come
you're going to get stuck eating the
week
so in those off weeks you book a regular
guys you don't take that much of a hit
there's different times you'll learn
different types of the year the book
star names
and there's different types of the year
the books bumps like me and then there's
different types of the year
to book basic guys a thousand a week
plus a plane ticket
just because it doesn't no one's going
to come anyway so
yeah it's it's that time of the year
where they don't lift the rock if you do
have
uh louis ck in there they're not going
to pay 75
the week before christmas
no
so let me not have louis ck in there let
me have ari shafi and joe diaz for 25 22
50.
it's two shows two nights thursday and
friday before saturday christmas
do you follow me
right so those are the type of people
you book
because then like that people will come
out if you book a no-name comic you're
going to get half the draw [ __ ] it you
want to book those two before christmas
there's strategies the first two weeks
of january you're not going to book
[ __ ] tony bennett are you
but you always go out the first two
weeks january i go out the third week
third week third week because people
start to get crazy that's it everybody
starts smoking reefer again the mother
starts sucking dick people start doing
heroin all that [ __ ] they talked about
they're gonna quit that [ __ ] wears off
by the 14th
by the 14th they're done
and that's when you hear that that's
when i come to town hey and also like it
wasn't my fault joey diaz came to
thailand i have a drink
the dabbit bars are pretty good that's
what dabba oh yeah yeah i'm not gonna
listen
we don't need cheap at you no more
because they're a bad product
we don't need cheaper chews because we
have to eat
18 chiba shoes at 180 milligrams to see
the devil i'll call those guys and i'll
get a box over here in those 180s and
we'll give them a run i guarantee that
if we bring the cheaper shoes back we
can only eat three of them for 180.
jesus christ uh
yeah that's 5 40. 5 40. yeah we'll have
a nervous break oh yeah i think we might
can maybe start with two
no
yeah
two is 360.
360 achievements you ain't gonna do
dictionary
you're way beyond that you got
you got to start with a nickel of
everything i'm pretty high right now i'm
i'm kind of regretting
having a little piece of chocolate this
chocolate smoother than smooth
this [ __ ] guy i'm telling you they
got into my car i'm getting pissed off
and [ __ ]
what do you got planned for the weekend
tarzan
the weekend well um
i thought i was going to the improv um
you don't want to go i do so then you go
what are you doing what are you going to
do with the white you got to bring it
with you no maybe i'll go one that was
all figured out um
hey you don't have a little truck
and then there's the ufc this weekend
too a good one right now yeah
i'm not going to be able to watch it
my show's 3 o'clock no but you'll dvr
that's the best part about having
you're probably right brother
oh my god
well
it was one of those nights tonight guys
we're stoned already we got stoned early
i started with me at 10 this morning
people at 10 they get together to have
coffee
and talk about the state of the world
we had a conference call
and decided to do like 92 please stop
squeezing the bottle people get pissed
off and [ __ ]
poorly
you don't like chocolate
now you got a [ __ ] earthquake in
healing let me give some shout outs real
quick
to the real jeremiah new
b berry
sully s
seo auditory
ferretti chris clark
brian majewski jared roberts
and casey sanford
i'm sorry about the short conversation
with liz carmouche
she's my girl i bet she was in the
middle of something like that
uh we'll get her next time up the [ __ ]
up here
last night or two nights ago lee and i
were having a weird conversation
and i felt bad about the conversation we
had
when i got home because i didn't
interpret myself the right way
lee and i have another mutual friend
that
uh cries
that things don't go his way
but he doesn't put the full effort into
it
and when he does it's for six weeks
when you're starting a podcast
when you are putting videos on youtube
when you're
like cassius morris
whatever you decide to do i want you to
look into the mirror and go i'm going to
stick with this for a year
i'm going to do what are you looking at
that chocolate i wish i had a film right
now
he's looking at that last piece of
chocolate
the worst thing like it's a dead
cockroach
i wish i had a camera i do but i'm not
into taking pictures
let me eat the [ __ ] thing why do you
always look at chocolate all weird
it's always like a challenge for you
just swallow it and drink the [ __ ]
you got water yeah i'm fine all right
well that's it bam that's it where's the
water don't even taste it where's the
water there's no it's just this one
doesn't taste bad no no this one doesn't
taste bad people wait give it a minute
you'll hear a gag effect
then you'll hear a water crinkling you
don't know yeah i don't [ __ ] know i
just saw it two minutes ago
you don't know i know
oh my god that was scary looking at you
so anyway last night lee and i
are at the bar and we're talking about
this [ __ ]
mook
and
i told you i told you that's what you're
gonna hear things it sounds like you're
sucking a dick
like somebody just popped in his mouth
and left it in there he's choking him to
death he's like i'm trying to talk what
did i do
i had hot pants on because that was what
i wanted to school play
leah and i were talking about vacations
and lee goes where was he when you spoke
to him i go this [ __ ] was on
vacation for a week
and lee goes i at least just had a weird
look on his face i go you know man
people really don't understand that when
you first get this venus going
you have to stick to it consistently
consistently
i have so many [ __ ] people who were
mad at me over the years
because i didn't go to a stupid party on
a wednesday night at nine o'clock
i used to have a rule years ago
i will do your thing after i do a set
first
but joey my parents are coming to town
they never come to town
i don't have parents and i miss my
friends in jersey
i don't have a chance to go back so i
sacrifice
so that means if i sacrifice when i'm
sacrificing on my own i'm sacrificing
your [ __ ] too so here's the deal
i'm gonna go do a [ __ ] spot you got
two choices you want to bring your dad
down
bring him down
you want to
see him
i have to do the show lee
in those days in my mind it was like uh
when you
tried to tell your mom you were sick
and your mom said to you okay you could
stay home from school but you can't go
out that's the most [ __ ] up or no tv
it's the same thing
it's the same [ __ ] thing
how can you uh get something started
just drop it like that
but then in three weeks he'll be calling
you and me
going you're not gonna believe this this
is what happened i don't know what to do
well you wanna one work thing and one
vacation for 10 [ __ ] days in a row
and i go you know what you can't do this
[ __ ]
you know i love to go on vacations like
the next guy but i can't focus
that 10-day [ __ ] like i said after three
days you want to jump off a [ __ ]
building
when something's cooking with gas
you just can't stop the [ __ ] train
and i've seen people do it and i've seen
them
take a long time to get back up man
years ago i had a friend
i still talk to him he doesn't live in
los angeles no more
i think the bottom from time to time
because
not only was it was he a good [ __ ]
comic
but
he was starting to pop some [ __ ]
movies
it's like good roles
a [ __ ] tremendous roles in fact
people coming to the comedy store to see
this guy this guy popped the movie
opposite [ __ ] the black chick that
won the academy award hallelujah
right out of the comic store wow i've
been on that [ __ ] how many times i've
been on that stage do you think i ever i
haven't even popped a short movie
i haven't even popped a drug documentary
out of the comedy store this guy used to
go in there four or five [ __ ] times
he's gone today
he had three movies that he should have
been set for [ __ ] life
especially how he looked
he could have had his agent switch him
over to tv
he could have been that guy in every
show the third guy you don't know what
his name is but he was on that show
right yeah he got a so what meanwhile
he's making 48 grand a week
and you have no [ __ ] idea who he is
perfect that's the guy you want to be
the guy at the farmer's market that has
a beard and you know he looks familiar
once he walks away you're like that's
the guy from the csi miami
and he makes 50 000 a week i'm saying
he was doing these movies in 98
and his agent switched him over to 2000
the television especially his agent was
a big shout agent this guy hooked up
with a chick and ended up moving into
the [ __ ] south
and i see
not tweets but facebook things when he
still does local gigs
this guy was a movie star
how to get convinced to move to the
south i don't know he bumped into jesus
i don't [ __ ] know
he just one day said i'm gonna [ __ ]
not do this no more and i want to move
down there and i don't blame him this
gets [ __ ] old this this high
and some people look at it for what it
is i'm not doing this [ __ ] no more i'm
gonna take the 40 000 let me know that
so this is the little movie and i'm
gonna [ __ ]
buy a house in [ __ ] louisiana in the
swamp or something like that whatever
i'm just saying this [ __ ] he made like
three movies with three big [ __ ]
movies
one i remember was baps
paps paps paps
and then the other two i don't remember
what the [ __ ] they were
but he was on his way dog
and one time tarantino was up there
watching
for something
and once tarantino comes to the [ __ ]
comedy store somebody's talking about
you jack
and then to how long after tarantino was
he gone
maybe a year or two [ __ ]
back to you brother i love when you go
up there and you go on stage i love it
whatever you decide to do with it you're
28 years old you got the world by the
balls
you know do i want you to go on the road
and suffer like i did
is it worth it
it's not worth it for comedy
but it's worth it for your soul
it really is to go out there and see
what people are about
do i want my daughter to go on the road
and do comedy [ __ ] no
if if larry came up to me or
or bobby came up to me and said you know
i want to go on the road right now i
don't know what to tell him
because i don't remember how i did it
i just did it
i just knew i had to do it and i
i did it so
so let's say i have these i have a
podcast two nights a week with you
should i be going to three open nights a
week
like like what are you like what would
you recommend
i think you should go to two of the same
open nights every week
become friends with different comics
go hang out with people your own age
talk to people with different
perspectives and a [ __ ] old guy like
me and
steve simone and whoever else you
[ __ ] dangle with
and god knows what you might learn
you might come to me and say you know
what i might book a room
and be the host
and you know you lee that's the best
thing about life
that if you apply to it you don't know
where it's going to take you that's even
a better that's even a better ride
you got the degree remember they said to
you get the degree and then you can do
whatever you want because you've always
got something to fall back on you got
something falling back on
i guess yeah
you got something to fall back on
you got a degree you know how to edit
well
you got a camera there's a thousand
things you can do with your life right
now
at 53 there's a thousand things i could
do with my life i could stop doing
stand-up
and just try to write this [ __ ] book
and keep writing [ __ ] books
just keep writing lock myself in a
coffee shop every day for four hours and
right
six days a week
it's a different type of job
and just do the podcast
who knows who knows what the future
[ __ ] calls
but you gotta get out there to see it
it's not on twitter no your future's not
on facebook
your future's not playing those games
and sending nickels to those poor people
i don't think niggles anywhere you suck
a dick on [ __ ] tv there you should be
shot and hungry you're a nice jewish boy
there's a [ __ ] human talent what do
they call that human trafficking [ __ ]
they got fake smiles and [ __ ] to tell
them if they suck 20 dicks they got a
sandwich that night
they're over there starving you put
nickels in the [ __ ] thing bio teams
is that what that is
it's not bitcoin well it's kind of like
bitcoins whatever the [ __ ] they are what
they call kind of like bitcoins
they just have their own tokens [ __ ]
just paypal the [ __ ] a yardstick
and tell us send you a picture of
something i don't [ __ ] know me what
what are you so perverted for i call
this kid what are you doing i'm on the
computer emailing people from you're not
you're on big coin [ __ ] watching
naked women no i can't i can't
physically do it all day well yes you
can give me the paperwork please what do
you
i can't physically do it all day okay
how about you big [ __ ] trenches all
day would you like that no that'd be
terrible all right then then what's the
difference between get your fingers off
the computer knobs on the women's site
paying nickels i don't paint i never
once paid for nickel joey uh whatever
your name is why are you my why you
embarrassing yourself
i know you went out there you just don't
check my credit card statements
you're paying for it with biker teams
whatever
what do you think i'm gonna have a
[ __ ] i know what the [ __ ] you doing
[ __ ]
you sit on the computer in the morning
you bang one out yeah when i wake up
sure but you're looking at those dirty
people
i know you you're a jew for a nickel
are you kidding me you think like you're
lying too no i i think i think you like
the guy last night i left my wallet at
home
that's the oldest juke thing that that's
jew 101. i don't give a [ __ ] we'll pick
up whatever you need but what are you
coming over here that you want to watch
i really don't say nothing you can't
sell it at all no you know something
then you come up and i don't know i
don't use biker things but you know all
about them lee
that means you use it i did the research
you did the research and you looked how
much they were a nickel and you said
wait a second let me do the math here
for five dollars i could see a woman do
something dirty you're on there four or
five times a day giving out bags of
nickels
bags and nickels they see you and they
go it's uncle lee with nickels and
you're gonna pervert it with them and
tell them to do certain things you don't
think i [ __ ] know but i know i know
everything you're disgustingly that's
why i love you by the way i don't i'm
not judging you i don't give a [ __ ]
i'm just telling you you're a disgusting
type of young man i like that about you
i love going to jiu jitsu i really do i
enjoy myself daily
uh and you know what why i enjoy myself
something i don't have in my regular
life today i put on some white shorts
with this belt i love these white shorts
but no matter how tight my [ __ ] belt
my pants always fall all [ __ ] day i
went to jiu jitsu on the way back i had
underwear now i had the underwear not
mixing with the [ __ ] you know in fact
the underwear is what saved me on the
way home my point is
in my normal life some i don't know how
i get close to fit me but you know what
fits me perfectly me on these and when i
wear them to jiu jitsu you ever go to
jiu jitsu you'll go to the gym you'll go
boxing class maybe cross training class
you go to these places
and you're not comfortable
you're just not [ __ ] comfortable
there's something wrong with your
underwear you know what i have i've
never had this problem with me on these
that's why whatever gym i go to whatever
workout i'm gonna do i have my undies
under there one because of the moldor a
cotton fabric two because of the [ __ ]
comfort and three because how they snug
me and keep me [ __ ] dry
like i said every pair of me undies is
made from a sustainable source motor a
fabric that's twice as soft as cotton
i'm telling you it is the best
nothing can describe the fit and feel of
me undies but once you try them you'll
understand why they're called the
world's most comfortable underwear and
why uncle joey tells you if i got
something important to do i got [ __ ]
me undies on okay they don't sweat your
balls are fresh [ __ ] like that and if
you don't love the first pair of me
undies i'll tell you what i don't i'll
do they're free
no questions asked me undies has dozens
of styles and limited edition prints to
help you make a statement with your
underwear whether anyone can see them or
not remember superman all right do me a
favor
shipping is free in the us and canada
and you could save up to eight dollars a
pair with me undies subscript
subscription plan get the subscription
or a single pair get 20 off your first
order when you go to meundies.com
joey again meundies.com
joey that's me undies.com joey for 20
off your first order right
and you're not going to be sorry i love
them if i like i said if i go to
anything athletic
i got me undies on you understand me why
because i want to feel [ __ ] comfy
it's tough they always whenever i was
like when i did happen they ride up so
mom i don't have to get some undies
comfort is the whole thing man for years
you run around uncomfortable and you
don't know it
until you put something comfortable on
uh number two you know what's a great
service
and a buddy of mine subscribed and he
broke it down for me
club w
club w is a really
good concept you know you've been in a
while now at your local store just
staring at a massive selection of wine
with no idea which bottle to choose
happens to everybody i look at wine i
don't know what the [ __ ] going on
most of us go with the bottle that has
the best looking label and we hope that
it's good well those days have come to
an end okay
club w is a revolutionary new wine club
that takes the guesswork out of choosing
your wine they have a simple six
question pilot quiz that will match you
with delicious high quality wine you're
guaranteed to love the best part club w
will actually ship your wine
straight to your door no more going to
the store no more being lost in the wine
out you love wine right we got the
perfect wine club for you it's club
w try club w what i'm gonna do for you
is this okay i love you to death
i love all you [ __ ] it's the
fall the holidays are coming this is the
best deal i can offer you right now
we're gonna offer my listeners 20 off
your first order when you go to club w
dot com slash joey and it even gets
better i know you all hate prepaying for
shipping so club w is going to actually
pay you for shipping your orders of four
bottles or more you're gonna drink four
bottles by the time new year's comes you
got christmas you got halloween the
[ __ ] kids knocking on your door you
got thanksgiving and you got christmas
so it's a deal and a half so take
something off your to-do list go to
clubw.com right now take the pallet quiz
see what kind of foods you eat this will
even tell you what to eat when you get
the wine they send you all right so do
me a favor again go to clubw.com
joey to get 20 off your first order
right [ __ ] now okay that's how
we're rolling here tonight
lee you're a little comatose tonight
that chocolate got you you got me
working over here double time on a solo
tip you don't say that you're looking
like the sad clown and i ain't mad at
you you know how you manage i know
you're getting [ __ ] [ __ ] up tonight
look at you
i'm [ __ ] up about that i thought i
talked all the time no you didn't say
much you're looking around like i'm in a
gallery twenty dollars i ain't mad at
you
just a lot of interesting thing in life
lately
this is it it's the fourth quarter we're
headed towards the end of the goddamn
year
and uh i got a couple things i'm working
on and it's just
it just uh gets hectic so if i haven't
gotten back to anybody or something
you know with the child now and now
saturday soccer camp and
it's it's it really has been
overwhelming lee and i have had a
conference call
three or four times a week the last
three weeks you know so you're sitting
there waiting talking explaining to
people what's going on it's overwhelmed
me in a way i'm trying to write a
special i'm trying to lose weight i'm
trying to eat healthy so uh
they're with us you know what i'm saying
we're bad [ __ ] soldiers
just like you i want to congratulate my
main man larry
he's going on to [ __ ] greener past
does this [ __ ]
instead of [ __ ] being the eyeball of
debt
he's going to be the [ __ ] salesman of
death
we at the church support him and uh we
love him and we'll see him in uh las
vegas
halloween weekend lee's band from las
vegas i think they bang it throughout
the state the whole statement yeah you
have to gamble and barstow and [ __ ]
you gotta go to boston get those [ __ ]
tofu [ __ ] hot dogs and gamble there
but besides that it's been it's been
great it's been a great summer i pulled
off the surgery i got the doctor on
tuesday go in there get my blood
pressure checked check my ball sack you
know me dog if we're gonna run this game
right we gotta take care of each other i
think i'm gonna get some uh blood drawn
because i've been feeling kind of i get
different [ __ ] feelings lately my my
back's been hurting a little lately then
it goes away for three days how's the
nose feeling the who how's the nose
feeling
the nose was a really good thing i did
i'm talking a friend called me last week
and he said he heard from the grapevine
that i had done it
and he has big money you know he could
afford like great doctors and he said
his doctor told him
they would do the same thing they did to
me basically believe uh
stitches that dissolve so he wouldn't
have to take him out because that's what
he's dreading
and he goes tell me the truth how it was
and i go listen
the first three hours it's a little
rough you're in shock from the
anesthesia but after that you go home
you relax you're breathing a little bit
and by it's wednesday you you because
you're good i mean you're not [ __ ]
going to the pool
and doing johnny snorkel under the
goddamn water
but you're starting to breathe and you
do what they tell you you spray that
stuff in your nose
and you know what i do it every morning
i spray that saline solution
and every morning i wake up and there's
something in there both nostrils i clean
it out i'm not addicted to afro anymore
is am i doing 19 rounds of jiu jitsu no
i can't why do you tell you that
is it do you see an improvement though
yes i've seen a huge
improvement and then it's how long did
it take to get off of afrin
right after the surgery never used it
again
when i walked off that surgery july 11th
i never used
effort again and your nose isn't closing
up no they fixed all that
nice and i want to thank jimmy norton
jim norton really straightened me out in
vegas
it was jim norton who said go see your
doctor and get it over because
once you get to the menthol afrin
that's it that's it you got a limited
time
before you wake up one morning and
you're not breathing because there's
nothing stronger than the menthol
it's so strong you got to go on [ __ ]
uh
amazon together they don't even have
that cbs and [ __ ] some of them have it i
used to hunt around the country and
they'd be like the one on lancashire has
it
there's one on the creepy side of
hollywood has it
and one place had it where would i just
go that they had it i wanted to i had
certain cvs's so my wife was just
getting a three block for me
and how long would that last
three things are happening yeah
four or five days in those days
towards the end it was like
every time i got a little bit of anxiety
i sprayed it
i'm very happy i went down i thank you
guys for [ __ ] uh
once i said it on the [ __ ] podcast i
knew i couldn't turn back yeah that's a
[ __ ] like i always tell you
[ __ ] i always say [ __ ] i don't
want to do on the podcast because i
don't want you [ __ ] to tweet me
and go joey what happened with this it's
the worst feeling in the goddamn world
and it's like listen you scheduled the
surgery
and you didn't show up there because of
your fears i couldn't do it the whole
way on the drive that's all i kept
thinking about
you drove me that morning no i was
canceling in a way but going what the
[ __ ] what if i cancel what am i gonna
say in the podcast tonight
what am i going to say in the podcast i
didn't go [ __ ] down there what does
that look like for me
what do we talk about the podcast all
the time health and taking care of
yourself and no fear
so that's what [ __ ] saved me dawg
that's what really [ __ ] saved me
that's awesome yeah man that's the way
it's supposed to be also
i want to thank my main [ __ ] the
geese tremendous the bags are tremendous
the rash guards are tremendous
all the quality is [ __ ] world-class
hemp
i mean it's all made in the usa uh
datsus i have been so impressed with
them the last couple of weeks they're
the sponsor of ebi they're involved in
everything you see them in jiu jitsu
magazine their products are [ __ ]
solid the bags are solid the the what do
you call the fanny pack the solid the
rash the rash guards are solid they they
they just have so many goddamn things
are there things go bad you can just
[ __ ] smoke and pray for the best you
know what i'm saying but listen i'll
tell you what i'm going to do just go to
dsgear right
deskgear.com.com just go over there and
take a [ __ ] peek just take a [ __ ]
peek and see what you injured you two
anyway i'm hooking you up tonight with
me on these now i'm going to make you go
to dr sarah take a look at the bag they
got the old utility bag made from them
with a thousand places to hide [ __ ] if
pablo escobar had that bar and that bag
he'd still be alive he could have guns
machine guns explosives water a canteen
a mirror a shaver you can have a
thousand [ __ ] things in that bag and
that's just half the goddamn bag but
don't believe me go to dsgear.com right
now if there's something you like i'll
tell you what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
knock the fen off five percent right now
preston joey boom get five percent off
your order all right again i want to
thank club w i want to thank chris over
as datsusara the sponsor of ebi and i'd
also like to thank me and me undies you
bad [ __ ] and i also want to
thank lisa for being a gentleman and
[ __ ] helping him with the move this week
and wrangled the cats with my wife we
had a good [ __ ] time oh they were
going crazy i'm supposed to do a show
tomorrow on animal shop planet
with uh what's his name i still haven't
heard from these [ __ ] so it's
one of those nights guys
so i'll tell you what we'll be back
sunday night have a great [ __ ]
weekend stay black don't forget no
expectations store ten dollars tomorrow
night flappers they got good wings
friday and saturday the melrose improv 8
p.m show you're out of there at 10
you'll be giving mama stabbing by a
quarter to 11. i get you home by 11 30.
bam you're at the farmer's market
saturday morning saying [ __ ] i had a
good time with joey last night all right
don't forget about me austin texas next
week [ __ ] stay black
so
foreign
so
do
uh